hi
my name is ryan and i'd like to tell you
about machine learning on google cloud
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
several of the different machine
learning options on google cloud from
pre-trained apis to managed platforms
ready let's get started
google cloud has many different machine
learning products for developers to use
these span a wide spectrum depending on
your experience level and project needs
on one side we have machine learning
apis which you can use even if you have
little machine learning experience
yourself
on the other side we have vertex ai and
ai infrastructure products which allow
you to build and deploy your own custom
machine learning models
let's take a closer look
in the first episode of google cloud
essentials we talked about how cloud
computing is all about getting things
done using someone else's computers
in the machine learning world google
cloud shares its machine learning
capabilities with developers through the
machine learning apis
with these apis you can gain insights
from data using google cloud's
pre-trained machine learning models
and what's awesome about these apis is
that they require zero prior knowledge
of machine learning
basically google cloud handles the
training aspect of machine learning
gathering data and building a predictive
model allowing you to jump straight to
the prediction aspect where you give the
api data and get back information about
that data the vision api lets you gain
insights about your image using google
cloud's pre-trained vision models
one feature is face detection detecting
different faces in an image along with
the likelihood that each face has
emotions like joy sorrow and anger
another feature is object detection
detecting different objects in the image
with a confidence score for each one the
vision api also makes it easy to detect
text logos and landmarks another machine
learning api to check out is the natural
language api which helps you analyze
text
you can detect entity keywords in the
text perform sentiment analysis
analyze syntax and categorize the text
based on its topic there are also
several other machine learning apis
including the video intelligence api
translation api
speech to text api text to speech api
and the cloud inference api
as a developer you can call all of these
machine learning apis from your code
using client libraries in programming
languages like python node.js java go
c-sharp php and ruby
the machine learning apis are easy to
use since google handles data collection
model training and maintenance but what
if you want to train a machine learning
model using your own custom data set
this is where automl comes into play
with automl you provide training data
and google cloud builds a machine
learning model for you that comes with a
prediction endpoint
there are several different automl
products including automl vision automl
natural language automl translation
automl video intelligence and automl
tables
these are all accessible via the vertex
ai section of the google cloud console
let's take a look at an example automl
use case
perhaps you're a meteorologist looking
to use machine learning to identify
different types of clouds like cirrus
cumulonimbus or stratus
with the pre-trained vision api you
might be able to identify that there are
clouds in an image but not what type of
clouds they are
this more specific task requires a
custom data set
with automl vision you can upload your
own custom image data set of clouds each
one labeled as cirrus cumulonimbus or
stratus
then google cloud will use this custom
training data set to train a machine
learning model
finally you'll be provided with a
prediction endpoint that you can use to
classify new images of clouds you'll
also be able to see evaluation metrics
for the model like precision recall and
the confusion
matrix the machine learning apis and
automl are great if you want to use or
build upon a pre-trained model that
google has already created
but what if your needs are beyond that
this brings us to vertex ai a managed
machine learning platform that lets you
build deploy and scale ml models faster
in fact it requires about 80 percent
fewer lines of code to train a custom
model on vertex ai versus other
platforms
vertex ai integrates with why they use
open source machine learning frameworks
such as tensorflow pytorch and
scikit-learn and can also support all ml
frameworks via custom containers for
training and prediction
vertex ai is a single platform with all
the tools you need to manage all the
steps in a custom machine learning
workflow
this includes creating a data set and
uploading data
training an ml model on your data
uploading and storing your model in
vertex ai
deploying your train model to an
endpoint for online predictions
running batch prediction jobs and
managing your models and endpoints
vertex ai also features ml ops tools to
easily manage your data and models with
confidence and repeat at scale
these tools include vertex ai model
monitoring for monitoring the quality of
your deployed models
vertex ai pipelines for orchestrating
repeatable training and serving
pipelines and vertex ai features store
for organizing storing and serving
features
to interact with vertex ai you can use
notebooks pre-packaged with jupyter lab
and deep learning packages
the google cloud console to manage your
ml resources and get access to
monitoring and logging in the cloud
client libraries and rest apis to call
vertex ai from your code
while vertex ai is a great managed
solution for building and deploying
machine learning models to the cloud
perhaps you want to handle even more of
the process yourself
this brings us to ai infrastructure
tools these give you the raw machines
and tools that you can use to build and
host machine learning models
deep learning vm images are google
compute engine instances that come
pre-installed with the latest versions
of machine learning frameworks like
tensorflow pytorch and scikit-learn
there are also cloud gpus which are
great for speeding up compute jobs like
machine learning scientific computing
and 3d visualization
and finally there are cloud tpus which
help you train and run machine learning
models faster than before
these topics can fill a whole video on
their own so we won't go into depth
about them here
so there you have it an overview of
several different google cloud products
you can use for machine learning ranging
from pre-trained apis to a managed
platform for developing and deploying
your own machine learning models make
sure to check out other episodes of
google cloud essentials where we cover
topics like storing data on google cloud
the google cloud console the google
class ck key use cases and more
i can't wait to see what you build with
google cloud
[Music]
you